laughs
so i just came back from watching this
movie and uh
oh boy i [ __ ] loved it it was one of
the coolest movies i've seen i've been
saying that a lot lately but hands down
is one of my top four favorite movies so
far this year fan [ __ ] tastic okay if
you want to talk about like a summer
movie that you're just going to love
that actually is intelligent as [ __ ]
check this movie out as soon as you can
seriously you don't need to see rise of
you don't need to see any of the planet
of the apes to understand this movie
like you can watch the other ones as
like fun treats or whatever but really
this film will like totally move you as
a standalone film this film takes place
10 years after rise of the planet of the
apes i like what's going on because
there's like an infection that's taking
out a lot of humanity or virus whatever
and then you know there's the apes who
are like living in the wilderness and
some sacramento no san francisco that's
what it is san francisco adele i'm doing
my review don't talk while i'm doing my
review
jesus christ
so yeah and it's led by caesar played by
andy circus the motion capture guy he
owns this [ __ ] movie man he's the
number one reason to see this film the
film's focus is mainly on the apes i
thought it would be like apec you know
you see them as supporting roles but
it's really about the humans and what
they're going through it is really about
like caesar and stuff and the apes are
so much more fascinating to watch than
the actual humans the humans are you
know they're they're good but they're a
little bit dull compared to who the apes
are because the apes are like the
greatest characters in this film like
the first 15 minutes is just them and
you're like i could watch this the whole
time i don't need to see a single human
but when the humans do come in it just
makes everything about this film is just
so good i actually got anxiety during
the finale like a lot of anxiety i was
just so [ __ ] intense what i love
about it is that if you've seen like the
first six planet of the apes movies you
know that you know the apes eventually
take over but you totally forget that
when you're actually watching this film
you just are so
hooked that when the apes and humans are
fighting you're like no [ __ ] yeah but
anyway where was it caesar andy circus
man he just brought this dude to life it
is beyond great siege like the cgi in
this one was fantastic the h looks so
[ __ ] real it's like a real
performance he did a great job in rise
but he did a 10 times better job in this
one you gonna see caesar's like
leadership side his compelling feelings
against humans after all the [ __ ] he's
had to go through with them it's really
suck oh man just
[ __ ] i love this movie it's a fresh
sequel and it's really emotionally
strong you know like yes it does have
like the action that is really [ __ ]
directed super well but at the same time
like the emotional strength is there
throughout it's really like a
character-driven piece and i'm not gonna
say a human-driven piece it's like just
the apes are good damn characters
everything about it feel personal there
were a lot of surprises in it several
things i was like did not see that
coming and like i don't want to give
anything away too much the ape you
become suspicious of early on in the
movie koba this dude he's barely in the
first one [ __ ] fantastic in this
movie too whoever this guy is don't know
who plays him awesome as hell and as far
as the humans go jason clark he was
really good it's all in his eyes those
beautiful [ __ ] eyes
those piercing
blue eyes
he made me want to cry
just from staring at him he does a lot
of staring in this movie it is primarily
a staring performance including caesar
and koba most of it is just caesar
and then coba goes
and then they like clap hands like fresh
prince of bel-air
another thing i really like about this
film is that there's not really a i
guess there's like a defined bad guy at
one point overall it's there's no one's
really it's not good versus bad in this
film it's really just a survival tale
like what's going on in the unknown when
you're dealing with different species
like whatever this world is they created
they committed to it and put you in it
as if this world was real it deals a lot
with fear like early on in the film they
say think before you hack and that is
like the pretty much the whole theme
throughout this film it is
and gary oldman good job too old man you
did a great job
he's barely in it kind of interesting
but it's a scary old man you know he's
got to mention the guy's [ __ ] awesome
let me get straight to the point here
all in all i gotta say dawn of the
planet of the apes got it super duper
[ __ ] ryan the apnosaurus right
all right guys thanks for checking out
my review for dawn of the planet of the
apes why don't you go ahead scroll that
comment box below and tell me have you
ever thought about doing it with an ape
don't worry it's a youtube name
someone's gonna know it's really you
talking i wanna throw out there you can
follow me on twitter and vine and all
that [ __ ] [ __ ] you know what it all
is another thing you to throw out there
doing a spoiler review of dawn of the
planet of the apes with adele
yes adele aussie hot as [ __ ]
would love to
do ape-like animalistic things with her
if you know what i mean
and last but not least if you want to
get updated every time one of my reviews
our videos is out go and click on this
button by my dick to subscribe
the dick
let me tell you something about this
little caesar
he has gone ape [ __ ]
with his [ __ ]
on a girl before
take that sentence literally
you